why didn't Aaron lose his powers after
being eaten in season 1. normally when a
Time shifter gets eaten number one they
die and number two the person who ate
them will gain their Titan ability
however in Aaron's case neither of those
things happened and to explain why we
need to look at the source of all living
matter the source of all living matter
is the ancient creature from 2000 years
ago that attached itself to yamia's
spine and ever since then the spine is
where the Titan Powers come from now
when it comes to this pure Titan
although it did true Erin's arm it
didn't actually chew his spine all the
rest of his body and so when Aaron
reached the stomach his spine was fully
intact this is why he was able to escape
but if the Titan had chewed a little bit
more then it would have been a different
story